welcome back to demo rpg
we're now up to episode 16 and we're
kind of at the point where our library
is somewhat
developed enough to actually you know
start writing a real game if we want i
guess you know technically we could have
done that a long time ago but we were
sorting out some final systems
and sorting out some some tests just to
ensure that everything works correctly
and this was just some essentials that i
think people should know about when
they're developing their own application
but now as we're getting near the end of
this series well there's there's
really no way we're putting in enough
time to make a fully fledged game
because ideally this would be
you know some actual rpg could play
through but that we're only putting in
like maybe 20 hours into this a real
game of course takes hundreds
potentially thousands of hours but we
can at least hack something together
quickly as a demo which is basically
what we're doing but
rather than keep adding to the library
at this point let's go ahead and make an
implementation of the library and start
building a little game so what we're
going to do is just at the top of our
solution i'm going to collapse these
little guys top of the solution right
click and just go add new project
and we need to basically
decide what we're going to do
let's just go with empty project for now
hit next
and let's just call this we're just
going to call this rpg
prototype this one is an actual if uh if
we go to properties we'll see it's an
actual application so it runs as an
executable
basically and that's fine for now and
now we've got to make more design
decisions let's go ahead and do show all
files
and let's give it a main the main of
course is the entry point
and let's go ahead and also right click
on it and go to add reference
demo rpg because that's the library
we're going to use and then we should be
able to include
the demo rpg stuff
mo rpg but it doesn't see it because we
have the path to the includes but we can
just
make sure on all config all platforms
and we can put the includes
in this include directory part i guess
we could do it either way
you can go under c plus plus and put it
under additional include directories or
the vcc directories and put it under
include but basically what you want here
well since they're in the same solution
you can just go
[Music]
yeah normally you click this and go to
edit but you can type it in there
directly i guess we'll show it this way
click the little new line
and then go dollar sign
open parentheses solution
like that
and that'll get you to the root of this
demo rpg but then we want to go into
demo rpg itself
and then into include
and the solution dir already has a
trailing slash so you don't need it and
once you click somewhere you can see it
lock in and it'll tell you the value
it's given
and that's that's fine looks like we
want the other slash here just to keep
it similar to the others
but basically this will get us to that
include dirt and yeah it's demo rpgs
twice in a row because that's what we
named the top level project
and that's also oops let me just open
this in a folder view so you can see
just in case
so yeah i have my source lots of stuff
here demo rpg and then there's this demo
rpg here which is the library that we
were building and it has the include so
that's why we got to have demo every day
twice but now within the project we also
have the systems unit test and the
prototype
and uh that's that's pretty much it so
now we should be able to start including
stuff but what do we want to do here we
should see that we basically got to go
to demo rpg yet again just so that we
can tell what this include is coming
from and we just got to start actually
using stuff in here like monster for
example
and there we go it's happy so now
let's make a main here you can pass
arguments into a starting application uh
with the rxc rv stuff which looks like
nc
her aunt rv is the count course
and carestar
double star is
rv
which is the the character array this is
a double character array this basically
means it's a whole bunch of different
lines of text
essentially
and
well
now yeah you can go from here you've got
to decide what you want your game to do
most notably what you're going to want
to do is have a while loop and you're
going to have it do stuff while the game
is running so let's just make a boolean
up here hold running set it to true
and we'll just say while running
this might be really common knowledge to
you but i'm assuming that whoever's
watching this might be really new
so basically you perform your logic
and you just uh you know when you want
to exit you set this to false
you have all your exit stuff down here
and that's basically the gist of it
so we basically have this sort of thing
to work with now we're probably going to
want some stuff now there's a couple
different ways of typically running an
application like this sometimes you wait
for user input and then you update
things or sometimes you have time
passing and you update periodically
every so often whenever
you decide you need to update might be
once per frame if you're running a
application that has graphics just as
fast as your computer can go but usually
you want your logic and your physics
locked at some set time because you
don't want it to update way too fast or
too slow so you just say hey update once
a second or something like that oh
design decisions so sure we can make a
loop where you know we generate a main
character or you pick a main character
then you do stuff and maybe we'll show
that
but we we just really have to decide how
we're going to visualize this now we
could just use the console that's
probably the easiest way
so i'm going to set this as the startup
project and let's just run it and we'll
see that
well
it's basically going to get stuck in
this infinite loop here because we never
exit the while loop so it's just going
to sit here like so updating a million
times per second
and sure we could visualize it by just
going something like update
and we see that every time let's go
ahead and include i o stream for now
and we should probably have a return
zero at the end or
exit success however you want to do it's
probably just fine um oh that's the
wrong word
let's see how there we go or you can use
printf or whatever you want it's it's
fine so if we hit play here we'll see
that it basically just updates super
fast endlessly you can see it's
scrolling down here
and while there's nothing particularly
wrong with this other than it doesn't
really do anything useful it's a pretty
standard
setup for getting into your main game
loop and it just does your gain logic in
this while loop until you're done so we
need to establish basically a some kind
of game loop
and then some kind of exit condition
which is usually just quitting the game
or something like that but let's go up
on a little side tangent for just a few
minutes and just research basically how
we could visualize our game if we wanted
to because
here we go we're into just another
area where we've gotta decide so i'm
just doing gonna do a quick google
search of
uh c plus plus
game libraries
c plus was game libraries sure there we
go
and we'll see that there's just a ton of
stuff of course you know i'm making my
own the one called ancient archer and we
couldn't theory even just use that maybe
i'll end up doing that
but you know there's just there's just
so much stuff here we go here's someone
that put together a little list on
github uh mainly right now we're kind of
looking at rendering done yeah we
basically just need a way to visualize
which is rendering essentially so we'll
look at rendering and we'll see that
there's all of these and this is
probably
oh my gosh this is not all of them there
are a ton more so basically we have to
decide all right what libraries do we
want to include and i'm going to go with
none all right so we're going to use a
console to do all our showing we
probably want to clear screen i don't
know if i'm going to stick with this
method but at least want to show you it
because it's kind of handy in a pinch as
a visual update system
so we might as well at least show it all
right so let's do a few basic things
here let's make a map that we want to
draw
and let's make a little system where we
can move a character around so we'll
start out with that and we're just going
to use a vector or now let's use a
let's use a character array and let's
just make a 10 by 10 grid that you can
move around into and we'll make it a
little bit bigger we'll make it
uh 12 by 12 so that we can have some
edges but we'll have a 10 by 10 area
that we can move around into so map's
gonna look something like this and the
reason it has to look like this well
it's 12 by 12. if they're 12 characters
well there's a hidden
final character that is basically a null
character to tell it to end
the string or in the the care array so
it has to be 13 if we want 12.
otherwise like if you try to make 12 and
we put 12 there's 12 different uh things
in here 12 different exits it's an error
because it's too big it actually goes to
13 even though it looks like 12. i know
that's confusing and makes absolutely no
sense but it's just the way that it is
and it's just there's a final null
character it looks like this so
yeah that's the no character to tell
that it's at the end so uh yeah that's
just the way that these characters or
characters work but essentially we can
turn this here into a map so
uh we'll make those little small x's the
border or we could uh select them all
using the power of shift alt and arrow
keys in case you don't know about that
it will save your life and your carpal
tunnel and we can go control view
i think it's control or troll ku i don't
know there's something uppercase maybe
all right so now as our update goes we
can we can draw it
so taking input is where things get
confusing because we either need to
check for hotkeys being pressed or we
need to take a cn from the console line
for the next action and we can't exactly
do a live game while taking in console
input let me go care c equals get there
and wait for it an entry press and then
we could uh update the map
so we can make a little function called
show map
and maybe we do this all globally so up
here let's go void go map
and let's just put the map up here
globally as well so anyone can edit it
it's not const or anything so anyone can
change it but it's always the same size
so show map is just going to go through
a loop
and i equals 0 i it's last 12.
and then we'll put an inner loop uh
we'll just call it j zero well j is less
than 13 a plus plus on this one
otherwise we're going to have some
interesting happenings all right so
basically for each one of these
we're just going to spit out
the map uh that is at
i
and j now you can do it like i think you
can do it like that i don't know that
might work in some standards but usually
it's actually like this and then when
we're going to the next line of course
we want to put out we just want to put a
new line here
let's make a new line character and
looks like we're going to need some
brackets on this loop too that looks
really messy let's hit our auto format
okay so anytime we call show map
it should essentially
show this map now we can do another
trick here because they're going to
somewhat overlap eventually and the maps
are going to you know that's just gonna
be a console of a bunch of different
maps in a row so we can go system
i think it's clear you can go system
clear to call a clear screen i think
that works so we'll we'll try it so now
we can say anytime we press a character
basically show the map now why is it any
time we press the character because
get care
waits for a character entry so yeah it's
going to keep doing this loop but it's
going to keep stopping at this get care
and see what you press and then when you
press something it'll continue on show
the map flip back through the while loop
and wait for another character so maybe
we should have something here that says
like
i don't know
start it with a new line press
press a
press enter so that might be just fine
actually
let's see what that does so let's go
ahead and just run this press enter okay
okay it says clear is not recognized
maybe we need to sort that out is it
clear screen maybe
i don't know it's one of those but lo
and behold once again even if i don't
tell you the exact thing you can figure
it out
yeah clear screen is not recognized by
just doing a google search
system clear screen c plus plus all
right that easy
and you'll find some answers on it looks
like it's cls okay
so capital cls
let's see if that actually works
and
so basically it should clear the screen
and not keep filling up things now this
is a really slow method and typically
not recommended so make that for what
you will but it's a way to do it and now
as you can see our console
it doesn't have
you know it basically you know it's 12
this is 12x12 map but it's way taller
than it is wide and that's just based on
your console one of the things you can
do is you can go to your properties and
you can change your fonts
and look for a mono space font and that
might help
but the new lines are probably going to
be taller than every character and
there's color options here yeah your
terminal is going to be different of
course depending on which one you're
using
but i don't really see anything that
lets us change the line height window
size window position meh meh yeah don't
really see anything
another thing that's super important to
know you might not know this at least on
windows command line
is if you click inside of here you go
into a mode called select and it says
select up here you might already know
this but when you're in this mode
your program stops updating like
sure it says it's going and everything
but it's not actually going to do
anything if we press enter it goes out
of select mode or you can press escape
to get out of select mode but select
mode is a mode where it's like ready to
copy text basically so you can hit
things like control c so just fyi select
mode is a thing sometimes if your
program's not updating or not continuing
sometimes you're in select mode in your
console and you need to get out of it
just a windows thing and now we could
develop a system where
uh this
this get character actually takes
some kind of character that processes an
update for example so this is a way
if you don't want it to continuously
update and you only want to
update the map when you press a key or
update your character when you press a
key you can give it commands like this
and sure that works in a hack and maybe
for a text only program that waits for
user input before continuing so
let's go ahead and make that sort of
system real quick let's make
now we're going to do this let's make a
player
uh area all right so let's just go
character make sure let's make this
instruct because the player is going to
have a position and
we'll make this an integer
i'll make
x pause and y pause and we'll make
maybe facing we could make like a facing
direction
i don't know let's not worry about
facing direction that kind of gets too
complicated so we're not going to care
about that right now
but we just want an x pause and a why
pause and we basically want to keep them
on the map
so they need to be basically between or
in these blank areas only so we'll
decide what else the character might
need here in a second but let's just go
ahead and get them moving around a
little bit so and we can look this up
once again
uh arrow keys
character c plus plus
here we go
yes yep once again back to the old
google and we can see that
they're gonna have some special stuff
uh looks like they just have some
characters you can
[Music]
designate them to but there's probably a
better way yeah i guess you can do it
with these defines
sure let's just do this so let's just
copy this code here uh put it up here or
anywhere i guess really and
we should be able to take it from there
let's see what do they do they they just
do this this get character here
so wait we can copy that sure
uh it's not here but basically for this
get character
we can just go something like this we
got character in the switch which is
going to
check what it is we're going to use get
care that might have been a linux thing
so it might be a little different than
linux or whatever
but basically now we can uh
have an up down left right
all these different directions
and it'll it'll do nothing otherwise
well we can now say
we can basically keep track of a player
on the map so we can can basically
update the map
before we show the map like so
and we want to keep track of the player
position because uh that would make
sense so this is going to get more
complicated as we go but you just have
to think about every little logical
thing uh we should probably call this a
thing a player as you can see we haven't
even used our library yet but we will
or we could at any point we just want to
get a way to show them on the map
because i was thinking here basically
we're going to get a player on the map
we'll get a monster on the map and maybe
we'll have you walk up to him and then
start a battle and that'll be enough for
this particular episode to at least give
you like an example of how you could uh
do it but you know this is really
pretty ghetto of an example
void update map
so we just need to decide what we do
here
uh how do we update it we probably want
uh to update it with the player position
so maybe we want to actually hold
a previous xbox and previous
why pause as well just to know where
they came from if they're going you know
a different
direction we want to know where they
were before
okay so how are we going to update the
map here
let's just say wherever the player is
let's just draw a p in that location and
we'll just say
if
let's see
the map at x pause
y pause well we need player here
let's actually instantiate it there we
go now we got a global player maybe
we'll just call it uh
player one
because uh i don't know if we start
feeling real fancy maybe we could add
some multiplayer and some networking but
i don't think we're gonna have time for
that unless a bunch of people sign up to
the patreon or something otherwise we're
probably just not going to have time for
that kind of thing all right
so
there we go
and we need to check this again some if
it is not equal
to an x character because the x's are
walls and we'll we'll add them to it
we'll just say
the map at that position equals
well we'll make it a capital p and what
about the old position where it was we
need to update this map in total so
we need to handle the previous position
too so we would have to say something
like
the previous and
other previous here
much copy page there we go
we'll just set this to blank and now we
need to
finalize and just update these positions
so basically we're going to have to say
well
now the previous position is the current
position basically update for next move
and same thing with why pause here
if you think about it it'll make sense
i'll leave a few comments in here just
to
make sure it makes as much sense as
possible check
that the player hadn't moved to a wall
all right
so that's the first thing
and if they didn't that's the not equals
here if they didn't move into the wall
they're all the character
at new location
make old location a
lactation
what's on my mind make old location
a
blank
area
and then
update
current
location
to
be
previous
before next update there we go
so that's basically it now we also want
to handle this case right here of the
else case what if they are moving into a
wall well in that case we just want to
say that they didn't move basically we
want to set them back to the previous
location so it would look like this
except in reverse
because based on
the way that this is updating
so if they do move
you know we're holding their previous
location and if they try to move again
and they move into walls or it's going
to set them back to where they already
work that way you just can't move into
walls
so there's some pretty straightforward
logic to just update the map based on
the player location and not let them
move into the walls and we're going to
draw p wherever they are so the way we
want to move them
is based on these this get character if
they move up we'll just move them up
we'll just say
player one dot x pause
uh let's see
now we gotta think about this it's gonna
be a little confusing maybe
but basically
we gotta think of this at the top left
is zero zero and down here as
uh i guess it would be 12 13 or 11 13 i
don't know something like that but
basically this should work without us
having to really overanalyze that but if
they go up
x is going to go minus minus they go
down
wait let's think about this see x
is going to be this one here and that is
going to be which row basically
and this one is how far along the row or
which column so it's kind of a row
column set up so x being the row yeah
it's going to be plus or minus going up
or down the rows
and if you go left of course you can
imagine what this is it's just the y
pause
minus minus
and plus plus to move right or advance
along and if you press some any other
key it's going to do nothing at all and
another thing we want to do here
that it's going to be
maybe a little weird here but basically
after we get character we want to clear
the io stream because the input stream
could have a bunch of junk data and if
you're just spamming keys so basically
we want to do a cn dot
ignore i guess this would be standard
and then we say till what or what's the
stream size we'll say up to 100
characters or to a new line
now basically that's just gonna ignore
any further entry beyond this character
up to a new line and uh
yeah that that should just help produce
some
some input errors potentially
then we call update map which is going
to also handle moving the player or
maybe we should call this like new
player so let's just call this move
player on map it's probably a better
name move player on map and then show
map
and then start all over again now let's
go ahead and take a look at what this
does let's see if this works as expected
press enter
okay well our characters we don't have
an initial position so that's kind of an
issue here
let's make the initial position uh three
three and three so let's start somewhere
near the middle here again
we need
some initial positions here too all
right that's going to should work a
little bit better we should actually
see them on the map
oh and now that we're ignoring
this new line this didn't quite work as
i expected now that we're ignoring this
new line it's actually we have to press
enter twice so it's a little awkward but
let's just take that out for now and
while we're moving around it's not
really doing what we expect it's not
updating the map it's not trolling and
we have to analyze
why it's possible that this switch
statement is not working correct as uh i
don't know oh this is just kind of wrong
too
we should get the character and then
check what c is
so just
this should make a lot more sense
what is it doing oh it's at the stopping
point again
all right let's just see what it does
why don't we just put stopping points at
all these cases and see if it actually
hits anyway it just lets us continue
doing stuff until
yeah so these scan codes
are not correct for these
arrow
it's basically what it comes down to
so what are we supposed to do about that
well
we can just do a literal check for what
these are yeah that's probably going to
be better
okay what if we just forget about all
these for a second
let's just go like this
see out
oh it's hitting clear screen
so that's kind of messing it up let's
put it at the bottom of the show map
here
there we go so now it should clear it as
soon as it displays it because that
doesn't work
and it basically just says it's always c
help
that's because we're not too bright we
need the actual c variable not the
character c uh
all right and it's displaying nothing
for the arrows so they are
some internal code
maybe we need to display that
okay well it's possible that
well that this is just not something you
can do
because it looks like we do have an
answer here there's no standard way to
process special k's skis console output
c plus plus we simply can't display
uh
maybe we just use something other than
the arrow keys all right let's this this
is becoming a nightmare with the arrow
keys so let's just forget about it and
let's just say let's just use asdf
okay w's up
s is down
a is left
b is right okay let's just do that
and this should actually work
with any luck
okay well the player is showing
momentarily and then they're
disappearing so we're closer
but you still you might notice we have
to press
enter every time after this get care and
that's that's actually kind of annoying
but yeah that's why nobody typically
uses these consoles or they use some
special thing to process it quicker
okay these don't work
we're not using string oh we did we're
calling this move player too often is
the problem yeah we're just calling this
move player too often and it's just
constantly uh doing this stuff which we
don't want it to do
so
that's fine we just want to do another
check
to make sure they're not the same
basically
so let's just put an and here and go
player one
dot xbox not
equal to player one dot
previous at pause or now we need to put
these
parentheses together
so we need to check all the things at
once so we just don't want to update
things unless the player actually moved
oh yeah
we want to check that
they're not moving into a wall and that
they're not in the same location that
they're already in because we don't need
to process updates in that case in fact
we don't need to do anything in this
case so we could just go like this and
just return if that's the case
because we just you know there's no work
to do
if they haven't moved so let's just do
that
that should simplify a little bit
uh if they haven't you earn and do
nothing
otherwise we process their updates okay
let's try that oh it's asp app
right
yeah they're not it's not working still
are we brought into this case we had
again all the time
or is it one of these that's messed up
let's actually place the player on the
map to begin with guess that makes sense
x pause y pause
capital p
that way we should at least
show them to begin with we should
probably show the map to begin with
let's forget about this press enter
thing
let's instead put
move with uh
wasp
that way the player knows what to do
to some extent okay
what's going on
oh we hit a break point okay so it's
actually hitting the breakpoints that's
that's fine that's good
all right why isn't the player moving
now
this is some real annoyance why is the
player not moving
oh because of this
i guess we gotta
majorly rethink this logic for days okay
now we don't want an or case here
we need an ants both of these need to be
true
know we need these to be okay this logic
was just wrong so it was just returning
every time and never moved so if the x
pause and the y pause are the same they
haven't moved to nothing okay
yeah now it should work
let's move right move right move right
yeah there we go
hit a wall doesn't let us go right let's
go down
we gotta hit enter in between every move
but at least it works
and we have a player moving around the
map
so what next okay well let's
let's bring in our library and actually
do a few things we got monster let's
also include
uh well let's just include layer
character
all right and let's
give this player character
an actual player player character
uh us and we'll just make it default
construct
to whatever we want
now we have to fill it out something
this is probably going to be a compiler
error let's have a let's have a check
yeah because it's attempting
if we look at our error here bring it
over second attempting a deleted
function so now what we have to do is
instantiate it as something so maybe we
wouldn't
actually do anything with this till
we bring it in so we go with something
like
player
we'd have to take a uh
player character
delegate star
here class we'll call it and we delete
all the other ones
and we could say that this is going to
be
our way it's going to be us rather kill
us
if care class
there
and now we'd be able to access all of
that
and we need to instantiate player one
somewhere and we probably need to put
this in here
so we'll pass it in like so
and so i guess we want to do it by
reference in this case honest reference
probably no we can't do it by pause
reference it's got to edit the actual
player so it needs a reference to the
player alright so let's make our
character
so what we can do here is we can do
something cool we can go
choose a class
and then we can give them some options
here
like we'll say
one for cleric uh
and we're gonna do this i guess we'll
just do a couple spaces here two
yeah
one i don't know
we'll just try to make it as clear as
possible one equals cleric two equals
warrior
i'm gonna break a new line here
three is rogue
and four
is wizard all right and we just wait for
character input
uh we can just go
yeah that should be fine there we could
just go
uh cn
oh let's do a string here
or i guess we could do it we could do a
multiple different things let's use
string just because it's easier
call it choice all right now let's do an
integer
and
choice
all
equals
yeah we need to get care and we'll say
we'll do this a little differently all
right we're gonna
make some decisions here and choice
equals i will just say start it out of
zero and we'll say while choice
equals
zero
will ask for the selection piece
now you might think what if they enter
in a non-zero it's going to continue on
well we can just go something we can
just say
that if
i don't know we'll just lock it in place
basically if choice is uh
less than one or joyce is greater than
five or four
now those are all invalid and we'll just
set choice to zero that way it continues
to loop otherwise
we'll continue on and we'll just go
let's go ahead and make this player
somewhere
let's make the player a pointer all
right let's go
and that's just so it doesn't
instantiate right away oh main character
make it a point
so it's just going to be a null pointer
so it's global here so anyone can access
it
and then we can just switch on this
choice
switch
on choice
case 0
we'll say main character equals
new main character with a
new
one zero zeros clear
new player
and it doesn't know what that is
so we just need to include all those
classes here and i think we have a
all-in-one header that we made just for
this case
yeah playable classes forward
playable
classes forward that way just includes
all of them at once
okay so here we are
this is new player character
and does that work
he wants a pointer
to a pc type so yeah this has got to be
cleric
uh why doesn't like this i don't know i
guess we're going to have to find out a
break here and just put all these other
cases in here
they're essentially going to be the same
let's just do some copy pasta action
ctrl d just update accordingly
this last one should be default
probably we just want to throw an error
so we'll turn like
negative
200
failed to make player character
new warrior there
rogue here
and new wizard here now i think the
problem with this is these need to be
scoped because we're creating variables
so let's just go ahead and do that
put them in their own scope for each of
these cases i think that's the case
because we're using
new warrior and stuff like that in here
don't exactly know why it's complaining
we'll figure it out in a second switch
statements seem to work differently in
every language
get the formatting key okay so what's
this problem here not be designed and
entity type player oh okay
so we need to call this just
player it's a it's our new struct that
we made here up here this one right
right here
and that uh delegates out this player
character once again further
see if that's
gonna work correctly
yeah because that's gonna
take this pointer and instantiate it
with that pointer once again uh let's
just see if this works
we gotta change all these the main
character
and in this case it's something like
this
update the map there to start and uh now
these are all
pointers as well and then this is also
main character so we can just
change we can just do a select update
here say this is now main
character
but we want to get
we don't want to update this move player
that's got its own thing going on just
these three
and we want to pass in the main
character here but it wants a reference
to it so we need to de-reference the
point
now we'll have a reference to it
and if we have any null pointer errors
we will get some crashes but we
shouldn't have any this should be pretty
fully defined compiles correctly
choose a class let's choose cleric
and see what it does looks like it's uh
not doing anything why not so what's
happening here is it's evaluating this
as a character not a number so get
character only gets characters it
doesn't get numbers
let's go like this
let's just pipe it in
see if it's happy with that let's try to
actually pick a class okay let's let's
pick his class now it did a clear screen
before we actually got to see all the
stuff
but it looks like it did get through
instantiating the character and
everything so now we do have a character
so basically what we want to do at this
point
is in our little uh update thing we
probably want to go through some turns
because you know we got the we got the
player set up now we can actually do
stuff with him
we're making we're moving forward using
our library okay this is a good sign
fellas it's a good sign
but we need to decide what our game is
going to do at this point and of course
the options are really in it's endless
so
naturally we have hit points let's just
fight something let's just put a monster
at a random location
and run into him and then battle it that
that should be fine
now we already have
we already know what a monster is we've
got it included let's just make the
monster somewhere we'll just make it
global for now but really we probably
want a generator of some sort uh batty
we'll just call it batty
and if we go look at monster we'll see
its default values it's got nothing it's
not even going to allow this to compile
because monster is deleted we at least
need to give it hp and some damage
that's all it really needs for now
so we'll just go ahead and put that in
here let's say it's got 10 hp and it
does one to three damage per attack
and that should be good enough to get
started
maybe we'll just it needs a location and
stuff too kind of like the player as a
location
but uh we can just hack that for the
moment uh let's make it let's go ahead
and make a destruct
uh monster sure
uh all right we'll call it like
i don't know i just want to
i'm tired of naming stuff i'm tired of
making design decisions i'd rather just
have all that ready to go and program
something personally
so
i don't know i could probably
use a job where the design is already
done and i just need to instantiate it
that that would be great but uh that's
not what's happening right now so
we gotta come up with the name struct
sure we'll just call it a fightable
because we gotta call it something we'll
put a monster in here give them those
default values
let's give them a position
and
there we go let's make a constructor
let's take uh
hp
min
max just for damage and instantiate this
monster as so
export it as fast as possible basically
there we go let's uh delete the default
constructor now now we got a way where
we can factory these out just make a
fightable give them all the stuff and we
should be able to take it from there
so let's just maybe at the beginning of
the game that's just before well we
place the character on the map wherever
he is but let's randomly
place
the monster somewhere now we do have
this random and demo rpg so we could
just use that to to put them in a random
random location
why not so let's just go
let's see we got this guy
let's put it above the main
we probably want to put most this stuff
in a dot h file just to clean up
everything
ideally but
it's
it's fine for now a giant main there's
nothing wrong with having a giant main
maybe we'll just have one monster at a
time uh current
monster
so we'll just come up with a little
system here where basically you fight
monsters over and over maybe like a
little arena type battle
where every time one monster dies a new
random one gets created you fight it you
loot it you fight the next one you loot
it and you just see how long you can
last uh maybe we need an xp worth so
xp worth we'll start it at uh i don't
know probably give it a random value or
no but if we what if we calculate this
we'll start it at zero sure
but what if we say it's xp worth is
going to be uh hp plus min
plus max
all that times
two all right so there we go
we just get it worth an h uh amount of
xp
that ends up being determined by
uh how powerful it is
just uh just a little random system to
get started
there we go so it's actually worth
something and we can give our player xp
just a little random system i came up
with nothing too big there uh
too many parentheses really there we go
that's fine okay so now
now let's go ahead and make a little
system we'll just do
maybe current monster well wait we
already have a monster right we have
yeah we have current monster globally
here and we'll just start it out as
something
equals new current monster
and we'll take some random values here
so
in demo we need to include our random
from demo rpg one that we built
uh what do we name it we named it random
now the only random function in here of
course is the n to k random which
returns unsigned ants but we can work
with it that's fine
uh it just means we can't random
negative values which we don't want to
do anyway so okay so let's do this
current monster here uh maybe we'll do
it for the map placements
and we'll just get some random values um
so that is
in namespace random uh into k and
we'll give us some hp somewhere between
five
hit 10.
we'll give it a min attack of one max
attack at random
decay
maybe it can be somewhere between
two and uh
four
oh there we go
a little random monster generation there
doesn't like this for some reason oh we
spelled random wrong that's probably why
expected a type specifier oh it's just
what if we call this
fightable i think
not be it so sign the type monster oh so
this needs to be right by the one we're
composing here okay so the current
monster is going to be a new fightable
we'll give it some random health and
some random damage now we could base
this off the player's current level
every time
so we could make a function to do all
that uh which we might later we'll just
have this as starting out let's let's
nerf him a little bit he might be a
little too strong maybe he even does
less damage
yeah let's just nerf this first monster
into the ground he's just got to be
weaker they got to be able to like
guarantee beat him otherwise it's gonna
it's gonna be a crap shoot
so there we go
and he needs a location so
let's go current monster
uh xbox equals something uh maybe we'll
just put him at like seven
and why pauses sure
so just kind of make them on the other
side of the map or maybe we'll even make
them further down like 13 no not 13
that's that's not going to work 10 10
that should be at the bottom right
and we'll update the map with the
monster
uh kind of the same way we did player
except we'll make the monster an m
and then we'll show map
and then we'll do a while running let's
just make sure this new monster actually
shows on the map and there's no compile
errors looks good okay let's choose
wizard this time
oh we got a crash or something what
happened here okay i'm gonna look at
this debug let's look at
okay the build succeeded
negative 12. so it
failed to make the character now why
would it do that
don't know
oh
it's because we have these cases messed
up should be one two
three
four that'll do it
zero is invalid all right let's try that
again
choose wizard
that's move
now what we could do is we could say
okay maybe move to a battle scene once
we hit the monster
and then we'll uh have a little fight in
her face so let's go ahead and work up a
little fight interface and get that all
in here as well this out of the way
so that's basically what we need to do
we need to
take this move player on map and see if
it overlaps
a monster so at the end here
well
yeah we have a check to see if they
moved into a wall and that's all well
and good let's also do a check to see if
they moved on to a capital m and if they
did they moved on to a capital m
let's go uh
enter fight sequence
and this is going to take a player
reference and a monster
well we're already we only have one
monster so we just need to
bring in this player one we need to know
who's fighting but the way our game is
currently designed there's only going to
be one monster ever and that is going to
be this current fightable monster let's
move this way up so now we got to think
about the order of all this stuff
see these ones can be at the top
actually you know we're just going to
make a header at this point
let's just add a header to rpg prototype
just to get rid of some of this stuff
yeah we'll just call it uh let's call it
a second pch but yeah whatever we'll
call pch for now just some pre-compiled
stuff
and let's just move some of this stuff
out of the way like this character map
put it here
just to help clean things up so we have
more room to work with our main
basically all these definitions let's
just put in this pch and then we can
probably put in
any of these forwarding things too and
now we can just include pch here
now we should probably have an
associated.cpp for that i guess we will
yeah let's just do it
just include
okay that way it has a area to compile
into
and we need to make this enter fight
sequence void enter byte sequence
and it's going to be about the same
takes a player
now we already know we're going to be
fighting the monster and the monsters
global so let's just move that up here
so everything already knows about what
it is
i guess it doesn't necessarily need to
be here because it's in the pch let's
put it above the main after all
i think you know the current monster
though this here it needs to be above
fight sequence so it knows what it is so
that's a thing
so yeah we'll just put them both at the
top that's fine
it looks a little weird maybe but
it gets the point across we got any more
definitions
uh we got this fightable let's put that
in the pch2
there we go
so now here we've got
just our functions yeah
and they enter fight sequence they move
on m
and then we do want to yes we still want
to continue to update
after they move on to an m so
no return necessary here
but now we need to think about the fight
sequence
and we don't want to display the map
here we want to do something different
so
we'll still do a clear screen just like
we do with this
show map
but now we're going to actually display
some player stuff so
we're going to think about how do we how
we want to do this
and we probably want a file here so
while
player1 dot us dot hp
or get hp
it's greater than
zero and
uh we want
current monster uh we probably want to
do a null check on the current monster
if not current monster
just to make sure that it's actually a
monster
probably just want to do that since
we're not passing him in here the
passing by reference on the player
assumes that it's got to be instantiated
and that the error check is somewhere
else to make sure it's not null but just
the way it's designed with a single
monster at a time like an arena is going
to be a little different so
and kurt monster
monster
hb greater than zero
so as long as they both have hp
basically we're gonna continue on this
while loop which is just gonna
do some battle stuff
okay we need to do get current on this
hb so as long as the uh yeah it's
a little different on how they're
designed but it sleepworks it's hacky if
i were taking this more seriously and
long term i'd probably make it you know
a little better but it's it's fine
monsters and players are just different
they have different functions okay so as
long as they exist we clear the screen
and let's display interface display
byte interface which of course
right now is just going to be
some battle systems uh let's make a
i don't know
make like a p versus m thing going on
here uh let's just make it like a chart
it's going to look a little weird but
it'll make more sense as
as we go
you'll see what i mean i think i just
want to do the player stuff on the left
monster stuff on the right because you
know we don't have graphics going on so
we'll just do like
yeah something like this
we might it might be better to do this
with a print format
honestly this is just going to look kind
of weird let's see how
we can still do it but basically we want
to display their hp
but let's just go like this actually
trying to think how to do this exactly
i think we'll just have the player kind
of go first
and do some attacks now the player
doesn't have any gear they're just gonna
be wearing nothing at this at start so
maybe we should give them some basic
gear now using our equip and create item
methods
but uh you know this is gonna take a
while to sort all that out so this is
like potentially a day-long project of
just sorting all this out but
it's going to be a nice little text
based arena fight
okay so let's go ahead and just get
current hp
out of max
okay so we got to think about
how many lines this takes up if we're
going to try to align this so why this
would probably be better as a print
format
because we got about this many
characters to work with blair and then
we want to break it to the monster side
so
yeah we just need to consider that and
it's just going to look awkward but once
we write this once we shouldn't have to
write it again it's probably going to
look about like that see how many
characters is this
let's just put that many right here get
rid of this verses
and we basically want to do the monsters
hp here too and we are just going to
go
into the longest line ever because who
cares right
here's if it's a really long line it's
going to be get max
and then a new line at the end
so that should at least display their hp
on that line
and then we just need some attacks
so everything just auto hits right now
and doesn't really calculate with armor
but we could add all that in how we want
and but really we just need to
take an action basically
so we'll say like a is attack
d uh i don't know what else we got
i don't know let's just start out with
attack and there's not really a whole
lot else to do here
so then we'll just take cn
just take an action here
i guess we want get character in this
case
uh
action equals get here
could take a number like we did with the
other ones
while action is not equal to
a i guess
yeah
because there's only one action right
now so
let's just make sure it's they chose the
attack action basically to give them
just give them the illusion that they
have a choice although they don't maybe
we could we'll program in more stuff
later
but for now we'll just be like this
okay we'll just start it out as a one so
that definitely goes into this while
loop but this just makes sure they
actually chose action basically uh just
getting to give it a little advanced
stuff
and then let's see what do we want to do
if they chose attack we want to get
their damage and take it off the current
monsters hp so we could just go current
monster hp
deuce current
by player one dot us dot get
damage hit or is it attack i forget yeah
i think we just call it attack melee
attack
that should return
the damage it does it's a function
that returns
the damage does
okay and then we'll do the same thing
for the player but only if the monster
is still alive
so
maybe we actually want like an is alive
function so we could just take this
fightable
just go bull is alive
and we just return
monster dot
hp get current
greater than zero
so if their hp is greater than zero
they're alive it's not going to return
false so that'll just give us a little
a little helper function there so we can
just go like so
here's live things to make it
read better
typically you want to read as nice as
possible in your the main loop
of your stuff
so you you know we could fix it up in
more areas but we don't want to get too
far ahead of ourselves
so monsters alive we'll just have it
attack by just going player one dot
reduce
uh player one dot what does it get
oh it's uh yeah let's use the right
functions take damage i believe
and then we just want the current
monster
attack
and there we go we don't have any armor
logic going on there although we do need
that obviously for it to work with the
equipment system but i think we're
getting to the point where we've done
nearly enough for one episode so we're
gonna kind of just wrap it up and we'll
expand on this little rpg prototype
later
and there we go we'll just continue that
loop
until
someone is at zero hp
i guess for this one we can now just
check
is alive
probably want the same thing for the
player
so we could do that just go into this
player here
also make an is a live function
we'll just copy this actually and just
do like the exact same thing except of
course it's going to be now
us
dot hp or what do we have
oh let's get current hp it's greater
than zero
okay so similar function there that way
we can just quickly check with something
that is easier to read
very nice
and then we just want to check at the
end who won the battle
and we'll say like if player 1 dot is
alive
uh
we could say something like
see how u1
versus the monster
then we could give them some xp
so
we'll just i guess we'll just make it
literal here
and gain
some amount of xp all right we'll just
say xp gained
and we need to get the xp of that
monster
current monster
dot
xb worth i guess it's a pointer here
xp
worth
and we'll make that new line
let's keep it pretty fine as much as
possible here since it's our interface
and let's give the player that xp player
1
gain xp and we need this xp worth to
pass into there
okay
and then we could we could stop it here
or we could do an else
and the only other case is that the
monster is alive and that the player
died
i guess we don't have that check here
current monster is alive please take
damage uh yeah we do have to check here
so
we would just say something like that
you were
defeated by the monster
and then we could essentially end the
game from there maybe we could do it by
this fight sequence
not a returns true on win
false otherwise because if you lose a
battle you essentially lose the game
so we can go turn true on this is alive
turn
faults on this one
and there we go now we got a system
where we can actually win or lose and we
probably want to have that
somewhere else we could also just leave
this as a
now let's i don't want to have to keep
forwarding this bullying so let's do it
a different way basically let's check
the players hp all the time
so maybe after every
fight sequence here
yeah basically after a fight sequence or
after a move we'll just check that
they're hp or that they're live
if not we can assume they died
so that would be essentially be right
here after
move yeah it would be after move
character we could just go here because
they could get into a fight on this move
basically before this show map so we
just want to check that
we call them in this case main character
main character dot is
yeah they're live we want to show the
map
otherwise you know they're not alive
we want that message to hang there for a
second so let's just say uh
cn.get
yeah let's just do this
we'll just do like a
press any key to continue press enter
to quit yeah we'll just say quit you
have to rerun the program if you lose
sure we could have it go back to the
main menu but yeah let's just do quick
for now okay so we got a little system
here
a little system to fight the first
monster and basically what we want to do
after that
is we want to make a new monster so
within this big while loop
we want to set up a new monster
if they won the fight and put it and put
it on the map so
let's
let's go ahead and run what we got it's
the game's essentially going to give you
nothing left to do
okay we got a link issue here something
with moving everything into the header
the map already defined okay gotcha so
uh yeah we got this
let's get rid of this other
pch let's go ahead and remove this
it's just giving us multiple defines
having only one cp will be better okay
let's let's make us a warrior and
apparently
we have a messed up check we are not on
top of the monster but it decided we're
gonna fight it anyway so let's just
check that out
oh it should be equals equals not not
equals we were just always entering the
fight so let's uh fix that real quick
okay let's make us a warrior this time
let's move down to that monster and
battle
monsters only got three hp let's make an
attack we did one damage
we took one damage same thing but we
defeated him
uh we should have got the message to say
okay so yeah a little error here we need
this message to be on the end of the
battle press enter
so we want to press enter at the end of
the battle you can pin you or something
you know like that okay and we let's put
this back in that battle right uh here
now this way just it'll stop us
basically at the end of the fight this
while loop only goes to why we're
fighting once we're done fighting we've
got this end sequence right here but we
want these messages to hang for a minute
so you can actually see what you what
you've got what happened
and uh that'll be right here we want
them if it's alive to continue else we
want to do
break which is going to break out of the
wild so if we died if we're not alive
it's going to break out of this while
loop is while running
or you know other than break we could
say running is false
because we are controlling it with that
loop we could do you know if we don't
care about this boolean too much
just an optional way of doing infinite
while loops
uh we could get rid of this running
altogether
let's just do it this way because kind
of designing in this way where we don't
care about this we could instead
do the spider wildly i call it spider
because it looks like a spider face you
go four and you make a spider you see
the spider there
this is just an infinite for loop it's
the same as an infinite while loop
another way of doing this is you can
just go like while one but essentially
the only way to get out of these
infinite loops is with a break statement
and we have one right here so that'll
break out of it
so any of those work if you want to
stick with the boolean running like we
had it before that's fine too i guess
i'll just show you those a little bit c
plus plus knowledge there but uh the way
we're designing it where the only way
out is to literally get
killed it's going to be like a battle
arena kind of thing
all right there we go let's fight this
monster attack attack we won now it
still didn't
yeah wait we can't leave until we die
basically it still didn't show the
message so we want to analyze what is
going on here and if we look at this
closely press enter to continue you know
we should have got all these messages
and we probably did it just uh
just didn't seem to care or this get
probably had a return
still in the system from when we were
pressing get care
over here
so we probably want to do like a uh i
don't know
something to clear the string basically
i don't know what's going on right there
actually
this this should stop this should stop
everything but for some reason it's not
let's just put a break point right here
and see what's happening
sometimes the cn requires some really
careful analysis to
sort it out attack attack there we go
but the only reason it's stopping here
is because of this break point without
this break point i don't think it's
actually stopping though let's give it a
few more tests move on top of the
monster
bite it
is i press stuff literally too fast
started over again
oops
okay let's slow it down once we get into
this battle attack
yeah it flashed on the screen super
quick
but it's just flipping right through
this and it's probably because the
stream is not clear so let's see if we
go
cn dot
ignore
100 or a new line i think we just need
to heat that new line so let's just try
like that because i think it's still got
this new line in the stream
where we hit a and then enter on the
attack let's see and it's like that it
doesn't actually eat that new line from
where you last pressed it looks like we
got attacked four times there we go yeah
so with eating that previous new line
from the last attack
seems to be okay one verse the monster
gain 14 xp press enter to continue very
good
and basically what we want to do at this
point let's just make this sort of a
complete loop
let's count how many monsters you defeat
and instantiate a new one
so let's just go into monsters
defeated
it's defaulted defeated equals zero and
anytime you win a fight here
let's just go monsters
defeated
plus plus
uh it doesn't seem to know about this
yeah it does just hasn't decided that it
knows what it is yet
lies and treachery all right yeah he
knows what it is unless we spelled it
wrong yeah we spelled it wrong all right
and then at the end we can say okay else
monsters defeated
and we can you know kind of have a
little system where
we can challenge our friends and say how
many monsters can you beat what class
i don't know just a little something
actually have a bit of a score or a goal
to go for that way once we build up this
game a little more
we can have like a
you know ranking system type thing and
we actually got a little bit of a
playable game is it fun or not i don't
care at this point well currently now
not really
but it'll get more fun as we start
dropping gear and allowing you to gear
up and if you want to put
if you want to use some library to make
visuals for the game and make it not
just a console game then so be it but
the main thing we want to do is we
actually want to put these systems that
we built to use as
an actual example
so that's the real goal here all right
so let's just do one last thing and
let's go ahead and make a create monster
system because right now
create monster
right now there's only one
and it doesn't really care about much so
yeah let's go ahead and do this we'll
make this just return the current
monster
pointer so it's going to be a little bit
like a create item system and we'll just
go create an explorer monster
you know let's not let's actually make
this return nothing all right and let's
pass it a pointer to the current monster
and it's going to be an n
non-const because we need to modify it
if
it is equal to something let's go ahead
and delete it
so it is already a monster we want to
clean it up and get rid of it all right
because we're making a new one
it's actually i guess going to be an n
out it's going to be both input and an
output which is a little weird not
typically recommended but
for this system it's basically a factory
so and we're reusing
the same monster so this will work just
fine and new
invitable
and we want to give it some random stuff
this is it's hp and we probably want its
hp be like the main based off the main
characters
so we probably want to pass it the main
character stuff
uh so let's just go player star
we'll call this base count
we're gonna base how strong the monster
is off the players
data
so we'll pass in
a pointer to a player it's got to be
const and we'll just say if base calc if
it's null
we'll just return i don't know
you know not a good scenario basically
with it we don't want it to be null
so we'll have to maybe check that it
actually creates something
is that really in reality we probably
want to throw or crash or return
something that says that we messed up
in this whole calculation
or this whole create monster function
but basically we don't want to be
calling
uh any of these base calcs
things if it's null
so let's just base this off the level
all right let's base the hp off of what
do we want to base the hp off of maybe
like half of the players hp or something
we just want to be somewhere around half
because we don't want it to be as strong
so let's just go lowest
hp equals i don't know what's the
slowest hp going to possibly be maybe
the
player's
current level
or current hp i don't know
i kind of want to go off player level i
feel like that makes sense yeah i don't
know we just need to come up with
something basically
so let's yeah let's just get level
times you by
two
and max hp
let's get their level times
let's times it by like eight let's make
them potentially have a lot of hp
and then we can make this
first one
lowest hp
max hp
oh we gotta
go random name space here now this takes
on ends but it's going to
cast those automatically we should
probably be using more static cats but
i'm kind of just not worried about it if
i know it's going to work now we wanted
to damage here
so we probably need to come up with some
damage systems here too let's just use
something similar to this
a level thing
lowest dam
to max dam sure we'll do a very similar
system
uh
say the minimum is the level maximum
will be
times four
uh maybe times two it'll start hitting
harder and harder but the thing is our
players aren't really going to have an
easy way of healing so this is actually
going to be quite
problematic for them in the long run
probably and it's not really randomized
it's just it's going to scale pretty
directly whereas their h the monster's
hp is going to be random but the lowest
and maximum damage is just going to be
directly input based on the character's
level so it's going to be become it's
going to be predictable after a while so
someone that plays the game a lot will
notice that
the damage the monsters do is pretty
predictable
whereas their hp is going to be less
predictable because of this
randomization so i don't know designed
as intended sure that's fine and we
should be able to take it from here
this in out should be updated and that
should be it for this function
it's just going to be based off of that
so we do need to make sure we create the
player before we create any monsters so
let's go back down to our main and see
where we got this uh
yeah we got our main character set up we
got our monster set up
uh we need a location so let's you know
we no longer want to do this we now want
to go
create monster basically
let's see it's great
monster
passing current monster
yeah and we also want to pass in the
main character and that should handle
everything yeah we also need to give it
an x pause and a y pause so let's go
ahead and that same function the create
monster function and we probably just
want to random it
yeah let's do that
but we want to make sure it doesn't
place on top of the player but basically
it's going to be from 1 to 12
on either of these
maybe it's 1 to 11 on the y pause i
think it's 12 is a wall
uh 12 is yeah 12 is a wall and we want
to do this
we want to just check that they're not
on top of a player
so yeah let's just check that it's not
while the map
at the current monster's position x
pause
and y pause
is not equal
to
the player's location
or yeah let's just do it like this
so basically if they end up on top of
the player
we give them a new position
and that's it and eventually they'll not
be on top of the player so it'll be fine
we should probably put in here
an ore to make sure they're not on top a
wall as well
because who knows they might have more
walls later or you know might have some
pathfinding stuff going on let's just
make this one giant line basically we
want to make sure their current position
is not on top of the player or the wall
otherwise we're going to generate it
again make sure
that's not on top of one of those and
that should give them a valid position
somewhere on the map and then anytime we
create one we want to update the map
with these locations and then show the
map so we essentially need to
also do this sort of thing now we know
when the player moves on top of a
monster they fight it and that m will go
away so we only really need to update
the map m after we create it which we
could just do right here at the end of
create monster because monsters can't
move yet
but we don't really need to worry about
that now let's check out this fight
method one last time
and get that sorted out
where's the fight okay that's on the
move player moves
if they end up fighting and if they end
up winning
let's create another one after they
defeat the old one so we'll just go
create
monster
current monster
and that should handle everything we
need
and it needs the player for the base
calc they will have gained xp and if
they got a level then it's it's going to
be different is this one again player
one
we need to de-reference it because it's
pointer to it in that case
it's a constant pointer so they can't
change it but yeah if they killed the
monster we make a new monster and place
it randomly on the map and it should
continue from there and this should
essentially let us keep playing all
right so let's go ahead and see how many
monsters we can defeat what do we got
here
current monster was no point okay we got
a little bit of a bug here
oh it's this in out
just gotta change all these
now we should be passing in create
monster with conster right
okay let's try this again
i'm still getting a null pointer issue
here oh it's right here this in out
should be the same thing as current
monster so uh in my thoughts
i was thinking that this actually
shouldn't be
well let's see what happens here we
might have a bit of a logical error
yeah so this is not updating as we think
we i think we need to pass it a
reference
to the pointer
yeah because if we pass it a reference
to the pointer
it can edit the actual correct pointer
all right
so that's a bit of a bit of a conundrum
and still complain about the same thing
here
so we got to analyze actually how this
is messing with the memory here because
it's not exactly doing what we think we
are passing it in to create monster
but it is creating a copy of the pointer
so we probably want a reference to the
pointer
yeah we want to reference the pointer
here let's see if that works as expected
that way it doesn't yeah that's better
looks like it randomly placed it right
beside us let's move up
and over and we're battling attack
attack back we only do one damage so we
don't have gear
one versus the monster game 16 xp
continue new monsters down there let's
go fight him our hp is lower but we can
battle it's got eight hit points this
time we won gain 22 xp
all right let's see if we can defeat a
third monster we only got three hp left
no we got defeated this time oh and it
broke out a little before we could see
our final numbers so i guess maybe we
actually want a
just a final
get care here to stop it from
closing that
let's go ahead and move on top of the
monster
battle this one's got a lot of hp so
we're going to get our butt kicked
this one has less
like this one oh that's one okay this
one's gonna kill us yeah this one was
hitting too hard
so this one was hitting for more than
one total monsters defeated three cool
so it looks like uh with this system
with only doing basic attacks that do
one damage we can defeat about
three monsters if we're lucky and it's
probably going to stay that way
but once we get to putting on equipment
and using weapons and healing with
potions and monsters dropping stuff you
can see how this would be a more fully
fledged system that could actually be a
bit of a varying challenge and requires
skill and luck more than it does now
i think that's enough for this episode
just wanted to get a sample of it
working in some sort of system without
pulling in more libraries and uh well
here's a system and it seems to work for
now
hopefully you learned some stuff
i guess the most critical thing to
understand
basically for c plus plus y's is
understanding how this create monster
works once again some more pointer
knowledge and reference pointer type
stuff we did run into a quick issue
there
but yeah basically
if you're not pulling it in by reference
it's making a copy so doing it by a
reference to the pointer pulls in the
actual pointer so we update the real one
and uh yeah that takes care of it all
right well thanks for watching
okay i guess i'll say one last thing if
we're doing it like this basically what
we would have to do
is we would have to at the end here well
we got all these in outs we would have
to say current monster equals and out
because this and now copy is going out
of scope
and we want to set the current monster
pointer to it where it goes out of scope
so this would actually this should
actually work and not have any null
problems because data should be there
let's let's just check
yeah so that would have been another way
we could have fixed the same problem the
battle
so maybe next episode we're
actually designing ways to mess with
equipment a little bit and design ways
to just use more things other than just
your basic attack so we'll flesh out the
battle system a little more get the
arena going a little more and you know
this is just a we're just making it a
basic little battle arena because it's
simple but in reality you could do
anything
you could uh make it so you walk between
different maps uh you can probably
imagine how to do that just walk in
between different maps running the
different npcs that do different things
and you can essentially use these
systems
as you go
and that's that's the whole point and
hopefully you're learning stuff see in
the next episode peace out
[Music]
you